technology developed right here in las
vegas may help detect cobit 19 and other
airborne viruses
a local business makes a product that
could impact where you work or where
your child goes to school
the i-team's david charns got an
exclusive look inside david
yeah denny so you know we need oxygen to
live but it's what we're breathing
out that may help detect our risk of
getting sick
co2 monitoring is a vegas based company
making detectors for large scale systems
but amid the pandemic their technology
may have a much
smaller scale solution
we breathe it out every minute of every
day you can't see it can't smell it
can't hear it
ronald longley is talking about carbon
dioxide
co2 as it's more commonly known and you
could say
it's in his dna what this machine does
it's a uv printer his las vegas-based
company which employs about two dozen
people
makes these they measure co2 in the air
that could be leaking from these
massive tanks you may find at a bar or
restaurant
even inside a legion stadium but in the
coronavirus era
his devices may serve a new function
it's the canary in the coal mine
the coal mines here are everyday places
schools
gyms casinos even your home places
where with poor ventilation the amount
of carbon dioxide in the air could
set off alarms that's because a high
concentration of co2 means the air isn't
moving around
and viruses could be hanging there just
waiting to be inhaled
airborne viruses like covid are actually
transmitted through
primarily respiration and we obviously
can't stop respiration but what we can
do is measure its
effects a recent study by the university
of colorado boulder supports that
its author's writing detecting co2 in
the air holds promise for monitoring the
risk for covid
and other diseases we can breathe in for
the cost of a small monitoring system a
fan and opening the door
you can seriously lower the potential
for contracting a virus like hovid
this gets more interesting because
california recently passed a law
requiring those monitors you saw there
to be in every classroom statewide it's
to detect the buildup of co2 in the air
and in turn the threat of getting
covered the flu
or other respiratory diseases so we'll
see if the same thing happens here
i'm david charns 8 news now